c'est une élection qui est assez
sensible puisque c'est une élection sur
laquelle les candidats ne peuvent pas se
démarquer la différence va donc être sur
la rhétorique
nous serons une opposition ferme et
responsable la différence de l'extrême
gauche on n'a pas envie de transformer
l'Assemblée en une ZAD en un gigantesque
squat ce n'est pas une campagne contre
Jordan qui contre personne
c'est une campagne j'allais dire avec
Jordan contre le système il y a très
clairement un favori Jordan Bardella et
un outsiders Louis Aliot l'un a tout à
perdre Jordan vardella alors que Louis
Aliot avec un profil daoudsider peut
évidemment avoir une prise de parole
beaucoup plus dé risqué Jordan Bardella
pour le coup à une façon de s'exprimer
qui est extrêmement cadrée je dirais
peut-être même aseptisé qui est
pleinement assumée puisque le but est de
trancher pleinement avec les prises de
parole de ce qui était le Front national
du temps dès le Pen et de poursuivre la
stratégie de banalisation c'est
quelqu'un qui manie extrêmement bien les
métaphores les hyperboles les
comparaisons et ces figures de style
sont distillées tout au long de ces
prises de parole des moments où il
exagère la réalité pour donner du relief
à ses propos ces élections seront un
référendum pour ou contre le saccage
social et la retraite 65 ans elles sont
un référendum pour ou contre la
poursuite du matraquage fiscal et de
l'inaction devant l'inflation qui vient
elles sont un référendum pour ou contre
la submersion migratoire que Monsieur
Macron entente accélérer au-delà de cet
échéance il ne sera plus possible de
limiter ses pouvoirs elle constitue donc
la dernière sortie d'autoroute avant la
ligne droite on voit bien qu'il s'agit
de mettre l'accent là sur des données
plutôt anxiogènes afin de faire
ressortir de donner du relief à ses
idées et d'appuyer la vision qu'il porte
de la société qui est une vision
fondamentalement négative en tout cas de
la politique menée lors du dernier
quinquennat et lors du quinquennat
actuel d'Emmanuel Macron il y a un
problème avec la Seine-Saint-Denis un
problème non sauvagement de notre
société et le gouvernement est incapable
d'assurer la sécurité des Français qui
plus est la sécurité des touristes et je
pense que c'est très inquiétant pour les
Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent qui
arrivent dans quelques mois tout ce qui
va dans le sens du saccage social de
l'explosion de la fiscalité du
une immigration et d'une insécurité qui
est devenue totalement hors de contrôle
évidemment que nous opposerons à tout
cela derrière Jean-Luc Mélenchon se
constitue une véritable ZAD regroupant
les idéologies les plus dangereuses pour
la France l'idéologie anti-flic et le
désarmement de l'État le communautarisme
l'islamo-gauchisme la censure de la
pensée la lutte des races et le rejet de
la valeur travail
dans les esprits je pense qu'il est
assez intéressant de s'arrêter sur la
séquence émotion qui est une séquence
finale de témoignages de loyauté envers
Marine Le Pen j'ai avec Marine
cette relation singulière d'une
confiance inestimable
si nous sommes ici rassemblés plus fort
que jamais c'est grâce à elle
je sais ce que je lui dois
[Applaudissements]
je sais ce que je lui dois d'être devenu
le militant et l'homme d'action que je
suis aujourd'hui alors cet après-midi
devant vous je voudrais simplement lui
dire merci
je suis prêt à continuer humblement le
chemin que nous avons tracé ensemble
je suis prêt à poursuivre sur le temps
long la mission que
le restera pour toujours notre
présidente m'a confié il y a un an jour
pour jour et de le faire avec la même
détermination avec la même force avec le
même sourire et avec la même énergie
c'est une séquence dans laquelle il faut
l'armure dans laquelle le discours est
peut-être un peu moins maîtrisé et qui
crée en effet une illusion ou non de
proximité d'empathie qui est peut-être
ce qui manque actuellement dans dans
tout ce système de rhétorique de Jordan
Bardella c'est au tréfond du pays que
doit porter notre effort d'implantation
les succès ne finissent rien ils sont un
signal celui que maintenant tout
commence Louis Aliot et sur une
dynamique presque contraire là encore si
les visions se rejoignent les stratégies
de rhétorique sont presque antagonistes
il assume d'avoir une forme de gouail du
vieux compagnon de route c'est aussi un
choc générationnel entre les deux et on
comprend aussi
pourquoi il choisit de prendre cette
posture là donc il a une forme de
distance qui lui permet finalement de
créer un effet d'empathie pour la les
personnes auxquelles il s'adresse je
suis né en 69
je suis pas trop jeune mais je suis pas
non plus trop vieux
j'ai je suis entre les deux en quelque
sorte entre la génération de mes parents
qui a connu évidemment la Seconde Guerre
mondiale les guerres de décolonisation
et puis le monde moderne d'aujourd'hui
il raconte des histoires il décrit son
parcours là aussi l'idée c'est de donner
à voir sa longue expérience qui est
finalement son atout principal si ce
n'est sa carte maîtresse dans cette
élection une autre carte intéressante
qu'il joue de façon très forte dans
cette élection et celle de l'ancrage
local tout cela va évidemment dans le
sens d'un discours beaucoup plus
spontané parce que porté par une très
longue expérience on le sent un peu
moins à l'aise sur les discours public
je pense notamment à une anaphore un peu
maladroite dans une de ces dernières
prises de parole continuez
ne sera pas assez si nous voulons mettre
un terme au déclin du pays continuer ne
sera pas assez si nous voulons faire de
notre mouvement l'outil qui permettra
demain à nos idées d'orienter enfin le
destin de la France continuer ne sera
pas assez pour convaincre
51% des Français de fièvre confiance à
Marine Le Pen pour diriger le pays nous
ne devons pas être des continuateurs de
mouvement passé nous devons être des
bâtisseurs d'un succès futur on sent que
sur le registre de langage on n'est pas
exactement
voilà
positionner correctement néanmoins
le l'adhésion est très forte autour de
ce type de parole beaucoup plus
décomplexé beaucoup plus spontanée et
c'est ce qui peut peut-être faire la
différence dans cette élection ce n'est
pas une campagne contre Jordan qui
contre personne
c'est une campagne j'allais dire avec
Jordan contre le système il n'est pas
question
il n'est pas question de diviser il est
question de rassembler
il n'est pas question de clan ou de
caste il est question de se mettre en
ordre de bataille pour préparer les
élections à venir ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il y a plus d'âmes et plus de
cœur dans les discours de Louis Aliot et
Jordan Bardella avait son doute une
marge de progression justement sur cette
aspect là sur cette dynamique là du
discours qui est celle d'être en
capacité de fendre l'armure de se livrer
et de livrer un peu de soi et sont très
attentifs l'un et l'autre à dire du bien
de l'autre et à admettre chez l'autre de
grande qualité le débat la confrontation
entre les deux n'est absolument pas
scénarisé leur duo en effet a très bien
fonctionné autour de Marine Le Pen
depuis de nombreuses années parce que
l'un et l'autre porte des thématiques
différentes et que l'un et l'autre
s'adresse finalement à des militants
différents